voici donc la momie am 5939 que l'on a
baptisé parce qu'à pâques
[Musique]
j'ai souvent trouvé son inspiration chez
nous et puis la momie qui est présenté à
pairi daiza et une momie beaucoup plus
anciennes maska avec des cheveux et des
ornements qui ne correspondent pas du
tout à la première version de rascar
capac dans l'illustration de 1941 donc
on a vraiment certaine légitimité pour
dire que c'est celle-ci qui a servi
d'inspiration majeure rêve
en fait la vie daiza prétend avoir la
veille tabloïd rascar capac parce qu'en
fait elles étaient présentées dans cette
exposition au palais des beaux-arts sur
le patin et son musée imaginaire qu'on a
rassemblé différents éléments tirés de
ses albums et c'était chaque fois d
inspiration en fait pas forcément
l'objet lui-même
et puis pour eux le fait que ces momies
sont représentés dans cette vision est
hébergée et visiter cette exposition
valide en quelque sorte par le créateur
que c'était bien la momie qui avait
inspiré son personnage de race car dans
la bande dessinée là en tout cas les
premières planches qui va publier dans
le soir pendant la guerre mondiale alors
la deuxième guerre mondiale 1141 la
momie apparaît effectivement sans
cheveux et l'appareil replier
effectivement comme la moule qui se
trouve ici dans nos colonnes
[Musique]
on fait des recherches importantes à son
compte et donc nous avons découvert que
c'est un homme qu'il est mort vers l'âge
de 35 ans il est mort au tout début du
xvième siècle donc il est effectivement
de l'époque un cas et puis on a
découvert aussi qu'en fait il n'est pas
péruvien lui en fait il vient de la
région nord du chili à la région nord du
désert de l'atacama après la ville de
haricots et qu'il était un chasseur
d'otaries notamment il ya un agriculteur
[Musique]